I'm here to see lots of fans and spread
the good vibe that's what we like to
hear it's been a fantastic Game of
Thrones Season four what a shocker
Warner who exactly purple wedding what
was it like filming that long really
long we filmed it over five days in
Croatia it was boiling hot I was okay
because I was in my flowery stuff but
people like dan who plays project pain
he was in like leather upon like armor
like they were just sweating their tits
off it was crazy and then I'm we had we
had a bunch of rotten food in front of
us they didn't look rotten but so just
stinking flies everywhere
it wasn't elegant at all but it was it
was fun it was really nice to be on set
for such a kind of pivotal moment in in
in television I guess it was really
exciting actually really excited what
was your reaction when you saw Joffrey
croak kind of amazed actually because
they did a lot of stuff in post so they
kind of did it the whole thing with his
eyes and I think they made like his skin
kind of come out a bit more like purpley
and I was really like wow that's a
violent death like a silent but really
violent death you could you could see
his soul kind of go to hell you know in
that moment where you can just like
fades out like wow that guy's go into a
dark place you had a little moment with
Oberyn Martell didn't me during the
wedding little flirtation it should have
been more shouldn't it how dare they how
dare they only hint at a homosexual
scene and not give it to us um petrol is
amazing he's in a quick attacked er it
was really amazing actually like hanging
out with Pedro and Croatia and and
working alongside him and then it wasn't
till I saw his stuff back and I was like
that's a different guy completely I was
like wow Pedro you you got the skills
he's is such a shame to see him go as
well because he was he was such a fun
character to have on the show and it's a
real shame that his head got
first squished like a bug squished like
a bug like a no it was horrible
who do you think Laura will have his eye
on next now that sadly over in motel is
no longer with us the ghost of Renly
maybe the ghost will Renly I'll come
back up and he'll just like slip into
lorises bedroom late at night and just
give him a quick hand job and then like
disappear again if only if only the dead
came back to life um no maybe loved
another thing with that that that Oliver
guy yeah but he's no good for Loras so
and I've not read the scripts yet well
I've not been sent the scripts yet so I
honestly don't know I have been told
that I do have another intimate scene
coming up but I have no idea who with so
it's like Russian roulette who will
Loras [ __ ] this season definitely not a
woman well maybe it will be maybe I'll
be Cersei ah
Cersei she's like not marrying him isn't
she I know I love Lena to bit I wish I
wish Loras would marry Cersei I think
it'd be real I think they'd have I think
to begin with they kind of hate each
other but I think once they kind of sat
down actually spoke to each other they'd
actually find a lot of things in common
fashion yeah give us some tips of what
to were next season in Westeros yeah
hopefully more capes I look at this
lovely cape here right I want this cake
back lovely costume people a Game of
Thrones if you're watching this give me
a cape like I love I love this I prefer
cakes my all marine capes that's that's
where that's where I think Season 5
should be that's a strong look so strong
enough with this flowery stuff I mean
it's nice and all but ah can you keep
Tiger cake let's campaign but that's a
happening for the cake definitely now
you were also in the trial Sima Tyrion
weren't he what was it like filming that
I mean that if the purple wedding was
long my god that was really long really
boring really boring um I remember I was
filming I was filming a film at the time
and I came on to set late because I was
I had to I was filming in Manchester
this film and I had to come to set like
halfway through like I hadn't slept
because I was doing night shoots I had
to turn up on set during the day yeah
yeah and I remember just been like sat
there on his chair and there was like
loads of like weird like cloths up so
you couldn't even see everything that
was going on because every day shoot
everything in like small little bits so
sure sauce is sitting around like
pretending to look at stuff like ooh
so I guess kind of like kind of boring
but actually when when Peter did his
kind of bit the end ah that kind of
stuff that was that was really that was
really cool but that was just like maybe
an hour of the shooting the rest of it
was just sitting around reading then go
okay right now it's my time to look all
right yeah yeah look intently at the
black cloth look intently at the black
cloth yep that's exactly and what did
you think then when you saw what
happened in the end with Tywin on the
loo and Tyrion with his crossbow and
then and getting escaping and everything
totally it's really amazing because you
film this stuff and you're bit like god
this is this is long but then you watch
it back and you see how amazingly edited
it isn't you go
did that really did that really happen
that like while we were filming I don't
really go on Tywin dying on the toilet
yeah man what a way to go huh
Charles dancers a legend and and yeah he
really rocked that that throne yeah what
gravestone
he had his horse [ __ ] in the throne
room and now he's gone out on the other
kind of throne
very well observed so he did isn't Game
of Thrones clever if we need knows what
he's doing
then he's died with him getting a deer
and he went out with him getting good
food with the crossbow as well Game of
Thrones the intelligence behind the show
never ceases to amaze me now what do you
think of this nascent relationship
that's gonna
bloom no doubt between Margery your
sister and Tommen with another younger
mr. Pitt pedophilic isn't it I mean how
old is he meant to be
Dean Chapman is a lovely kids he's a
lovely guy but I can't get a bit weird
when I see him together it's a bit like
that like um I don't know what's going
to happen really actually maybe it'll be
interesting to see I guess I reckon
she'll she'll [ __ ] whip him into shape
you know did you know
Tommen seems like a really kind of mild
meat guy that will do whatever he wants
and Margaery so yeah maybe maybe
there'll be a bit of a kind of
dominatrix bit of S&M whips and chains
all that kind of stuff you never know
it's Game of Thrones talking about
[ __ ]
as you were whis mentioned Sir Pouncy
the course has been the most big
sensation of the whole season what do
they surpass is quite a big deal these
days isn't it I actually think he's
gonna be here tomorrow signing
autographs it's just got these little
pour in like some ink yeah I I'm all for
sir pounce on the Iron Throne yeah cats
cats cats for thrones totally yeah now
to John Martin again been talking very
very recently just the other day gay
with Rosa moving far yes yes George
yes George flip off those [ __ ] Oh
some some people can get so intense
about Game of Thrones it's like calm
down just like just just enjoy the show
you know just enjoy the show it was good
to see him flipping off his fans it was
certainly a moment of what a rockstar
yeah don't don't speak badly about my
health
[ __ ] off too right George get on him I'd
also he was talking again about the
movie wasn't he what would you think
about Gareth Rose moving I'm all for it
that's the best way to go out you know
do two more seasons and then it had this
all-out kind of epic two and a half hour
long battle of Ice and Fire
and maybe these kind of like these tree
children that just come up with Brown I
think that's gonna I don't know the
ending but I have a theory that it's
going to be all this kind of elemental
esoteric kind of ending where it's like
you've got ice you've got fire and then
you've got like the earth and personally
I want to see the earth prevail and and
then
I I don't know I've got I think it's
gonna be really interesting in the
ending yeah I think it's really going to
go there so we'll see talk about in
season four what have been your favorite
moments of that season four I love the
bit where drat Brad touched the touch
the tree and he had the vision said and
he saw the dragon flying over now my my
interpretation of that is that Christian
right so we know Daenerys is locked up
her two dragons idiot and she's got
another dragon missing right my theory
is and this is Christian's theory as
well we speak about at great length
Christian right over here
Hodor no that one oh no say hi sorry
he's engrossed in the fans he's isn't he
good with these fans we reckoned that
bran is gonna whilst he's up in that
tree without wizard guy he's going to
learn how to really hone his his his
third eye
[ __ ] and then he's going to learn to
walk bigger things bigger things and
Hodor and he's going to learn to water a
dragon and then that dragon is gonna fly
over King's Landing like we saw [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] yeah
oh now the interesting thing is Westlaw
it's gonna be in all of this I don't
know all right in that dragon riding
that dragon well yes of quitte Kate with
a car riding a dragon with a cage but if
that if that happens then wow I can die
a happy happy guy yeah riding a dragon
with a cape Oh getting tears even
thinking about it then it's gonna
pleasure talking to you a daughter
always a pleasure fixing the city
wonderful thank you so much
you